[John:] Good morning, Hank;
It's Friday!
It's the final day of Pizzamas 2015.
And, what a ride it's been.
We've laughed,
we've cried,
we've suited up,
we've learned some art history;
and, perhaps most importantly,
we have made the accquaintance of Cheese Doodles Guy.
[Cheese Doodles Guy:] [Screaming] YEAAAHHH!!!
YEAAAAAAAHHHH!!!
[John:] But, all good things must end;
even the excitement over cheese doodles.
In fact, come to think of it,
everything must end.
In this universe,
to be is to not always be.
Or, actually, maybe not.
Maybe "to be"
is just "to change".
After all,
those cheese doodles eventually became poop.
But anyway,
the end of Pizzamas also means
that this is the last
that you can order Pizzamas merch!
My face in a nebula
on your torso,
only available until midnight tonight
along with the rest of the Pizzamas merch.
Check it out at dftba.com  ;
link in the doobly-doo.
But, if you leave Pizzamas
with no physical mementos;
fear not.
When Nerdfighter D.C.
complained that they were too broke to enjoy Pizzamas,
Untapped Inkwell replied:
"Pizzamas is just as much a state of being,
as it is a consumerist holiday."
So true.
So true of all consumerist holidays, actually.
Which, these days,
is to say all holidays.
But, speaking of states of being;
you talked about kind of personal stuff in your video yesterday, Hank.
So, I guess I'll do the same.
I have a mental illness called
Obsessive-Compulsive Disorder;
which, is often associated with anxiety
and depression problems.
I try to talk about that sometimes,
because I don't think that there should be anything embarrassing
about mental illness;
but, I don't talk about it that much.
Because, one: it's personal;
and two: I find it difficult to talk about my own experiences with chronic illness
because the central way we imagine sickness,
as a thing that we must conquer
and then put behind us,
doesn't really apply to chronic illness.
Like, when you go to the store
to get a card for a sick friend;
you go to the "Get Well Soon" section, right?
But, for people living with chronic illness,
it often isn't a question of getting "well soon".
Like Hank, I hope that someday they cure ulcerative colitis;
but, I don't expect you to "get well soon".
Instead, my hope for you is that you live a rich and full life;
and that you aren't marginalized because of your illness.
Which is a big problem!
I have a theory about this, Hank;
I don't think we humans like to imagine our lives as "random".
We need human lives to be narratives that make sense;
so, if we can't find causation,
we just create it.
Like, people get depression
because they're weak;
or they get diabetes,
because they don't eat well;
or they have heart failure,
because they don't exercise.
All of that stuff
is either totally inaccurate
or overly simplistic,
but we want every effect to have a cause;
and, when we can't find that cause,
we invent one.
Anyway Hank, as you know,
I have been very sick over the last several weeks
as I've tried to figure out a new medication regimen.
Over the years of living with my illness,
I've learned about how to make it tolerable.
I've learned to celebrate small successes;
I've learned to encourage myself without being cruel.
And, most importantly,
I've learned that there is hope;
and that when I feel like there isn't hope,
my brain is lying to me.
But still,
it is awful!
And, after years of relatively good health,
I have been reminded in the last several weeks
just how painful
and crushing that this stuff can be.
And, that's despite my having all kinds of advantages that make it easier to live with;
an incredibly supportive family,
total job flexibility,
an excellent therapist and psychiatrist,
money to afford medication,
etcetera.
Most people don't have all of those resources,
and that worsens any kind of illness.
Hank, I've mentioned all of this for three reasons.
First, to tell people who may be living with mental illness
that there is hope.
That mental illness is almost always treatable;
and that, how you feel when you are at your sickest
is not how you will always feel.
And, down in the doobly doo,
you can find the links to resources that I've found helpful,
and that the people I know have found helpful.
Secondly, I want to remind all of us,
that what we see in videos or on Instagram
isn't the whole story.
Like, my friends and family have known that I have been unwell over the last several weeks,
because it is impossible for me to hide it from them;
but, it is very possible for me to hide it with jump cuts.
And lastly, to say thanks!
Thank you for watching these videos;
and Hank, thank you for the gift of Pizzamas,
which has given structure and achieveable tasks to my life
at a time when I desperately needed them.
I'm starting to feel better for a variety of reasons;
from medication to exercise.
But, the gift of Pizzamas has been surprisingly important;
so, thank you for being a part of it.
Hank;
Don't forget to be awesome!
I will see you-
No!!
No; you will see me
on Tuesday.